7h44 elizabeth martichoux vous recevez
ce matin françois mais au en direct de
pro bonjour yves et bonjour françois
bayrou en effet vous vous êtes le
premier invité politique de cette année
2010 est merci avec merci à vous d'être
en direct avec nous vous avez écouté
sans doute le 31 décembre au soir 20
heures les derniers voeux françois
hollande françois bayrou vous avez vu un
président libéré déjà ailleurs où un
président jusqu'au bout comme il l'a dit
bon c'était des voeux classiques surtout
classique pour un président qui ne se
représente pas et qui donc s'adresse
pour la dernière fois
on sait en ce 31 décembre aux français
c'était des voeux et c'était des voeux
grave aussi parce que il est vrai que la
situation internationale et nationale
n'est pas exactement ce qu'on
souhaiterait pour une année fasciné
heureuse et donc de ce point de vue là
cette gravité étaient justifiées gravité
justifiez vous insistez sur classique
trop classique pour effectivement une
configuration politique très peu banal
c'est à dire un président qui renonce à
se représenter
bon vous savez bien que tout le monde a
en mémoire les derniers voeux de
françois mitterrand avec 7
cette phrase incroyable qui était je
crois aux forces de l'esprit je ne vous
quitterai pas il y avait une très grande
émotion et quelque chose qui sorte de
l'ordinaire
les voeux de françois hollande était
plus classique on sent dans ce trop
classique effectivement une certaine
déception par rapport à ce que vous
attendiez de lui mais il remonte dans
les sondages françois hollande les
français le regrette finalement ou salue
sa chose sa sagesse d'abdication d'abord
je suis pas sûr qu'il faille accordée
aux sondages
une attention trop soutenu parce que
comme vous savez les sondages ils ont
beaucoup de vent et beaucoup de bas
ça veut dire quelque chose au moment où
moi je n'ai jamais je n'ai jamais vu sur
françois hollande
les jugements agressif péjoratif qu'on
entendait simplement j'ai été comme
beaucoup de français déçus qui le
n'exerce pas la plénitude de sa fonction
comme ça aurait dû être le cas c'est à
dire que il fasse trop qui ressemble
trop au premier secrétaire du ps c'est
qu' il soit pas assez à la hauteur de
l'histoire qui était pourtant en train
de s'écrire et que notamment ils
refusent de changer des choses tout à
fait essentiel pour la démocratie
française
on va en parler mais il a entre autres
mis dans ses voeux mis en garde contre
la dispersion à gauche qui pourrait
faire éliminer son camp dès le premier
tour il a raison faire la leçon à ses
amis je ne sais pas ce que la gauche
veut dire aujourd'hui et vous non plus
vous ne savez pas et aucun de ceux qui
nous écoutent parce que la gauche a
explosé et elle a explosé sur le fond
elle a explosé sur ce qu'on appelle
l'idéologie c'est à dire la vision du
monde le ce qu'on croyait être la ligne
de conduite éternel de la gauche
aujourd'hui on voit que cette ligne de
conduite ne marche plus et que de ce
point de vue là ça appelle une
alternance et une reconstruction alors
je n'appartiens pas au camp de la gauche
donc c'est pas à moi de le dire mais
tout le monde voit bien que on a besoin
d'une alternance pour que chacun tire
les leçons de ce qui s'est passé qu'on
ait un pouvoir nouveau en france mais ce
qu'il voulait dire c'est que la
dispersion des candidatures est un
poison en politique c'est vrai nom
françois bayrou
ça dépend la seule question qui se pose
c'est est-ce que vos idées sont défendus
dans une échéance aussi importante que
celle là tout le monde parle
des élections présidentielles comme s'il
s'agissait de paris sportifs mais c'est
pas ça la question
un peuple doit choisir le destin qui va
le mener aux aux défis à relever les
défis les plus importants est la seule
question qui se pose c'est est ce qu'il
prend le bon chemin et c'est sur le
chemin sur la direction qu'on va prendre
alors justin mention sous pour françois
hollande à son est pris aussi à françois
fillon accusé de vouloir brutaliser la
société vous qui avez dit que son
programme était récessive dangereux et
j'en passe vous êtes d'accord avec lui
en tout cas j'ai un débat avec françois
fillon tout le monde le voit bien
et ce débat ce n'est pas le mien c'est
pas un débat personnel c'est un débat
que beaucoup de français c'est une
interrogation que beaucoup de français
se posent aujourd'hui beaucoup de
français beaucoup de responsables
politiques
et pourtant vous auriez selon canard
enchaîné conclut un pacte secret et
françois fillon vous vous seriez engagé
à leurs alliés j'explique pour les
auditeurs à leurs alliés contre des
circonscriptions pour le modem ce
suspense que vous entretenez c'est du
cinéma françois bayrou est ce que je
peux répondre en une phrase la plus
courte possible sur ce pacte secret tout
cela c'est de l'intox c'est à dire que
évidemment c'est ce sont ben et des
manipulations d'opinion ça je n'en sais
rien mais sûrement pas des gens qui
veulent du bien aux uns et aux autres
mais c'est très simple il ya au moins
deux personnes qui savons que tout ceci
est complètement faux fallacieux
intégralement bidon comme on dit c'est
françois fillon et c'est moi parce que
nous n'avons évidemment jamais l'idée eu
l'idée de négocier des pactes secrets je
ne pratique pas ce genre de manoeuvre
quand je pense quelque chose je le dis
quand je fais un choix ce choix est
ouvert et je ne je ne je ne manoeuvrent
pas dans bay dans des couloirs secrets
je suis un responsable politique devant
les français puisque vous êtes
transparents là dans la rue ce vous avez
eu des contacts avec françois fillon
depuis va déjeuner début décembre
non et d'aucuns même pas téléphonique
rien d'abord vous dites déjeuner début
décembre nous n'avons pas déjeuné
ensemble nous nous sommes vus et j'ai
rencontré un certain nombre de ses
proches mais non je n'ai pas eu de
contact avec lui votre souhait outre de
défendre l'intérêt de la france et on va
le voir dans quelques instants
commençait bien de constituer un groupe
centriste à l'assemblée nationale après
à l'occasion des législatives du mois de
juin
ce n'est même pas une question de
groupes de circonscriptions ce n'est
même pas sous cette forme que je vois
les choses
la france a besoin de centre vous voyez
bien que l'offre politique que nous
avons aujourd'hui elle n'est pas
satisfaisante un grand journaliste
politique écrivait récemment que entre
25 et 30% des français était absolument
insatisfaits n'arrivait pas à trouver
leur chemin et donc ce qu'il faut c'est
en effet la constitution la construction
ou la reconstruction d'un centre digne
de ce nom en france et ce centre doit
avoir deux caractéristiques la première
il doit être unie et la deuxième il doit
être indépendant il doit être capable de
se prononcer par lui même au lieu de
toujours avoir à se précipiter pour être
l'allié ou la roue de secours de
quelqu'un d'autre et 7 cette volonté
d'indépendance c'est une volonté qui est
absolument majeur pour la démocratie
française pour les buralistes français
voulait constituer cette force france
toujours selon le canard enchaîné
françois fillon préférait que vous soyez
candidat au premier tour pour juguler
les justement les centristes de droite
tenté par macron
sas qui vous ai fait des intérêts
communs je vous ai dit que tout cela
était de l'intox ne m'obligez pas s'il y
avait un pas que vous ne diriez pas là
tant vous la fiev
elizabeth martichoux 2 arrêtons-nous une
seconde quand je dis qu'il n'y a rien de
ce type de manoeuvre que je n'ai pas
cela en pet et que je n'y participe pas
je vous dis aussi ouvertement que
possible la vérité est donc vous je vous
encourage à ne pas dire s'il y avait un
pacte vous nous en parleriez pas parce
que il n'y aura jamais avec mois de
manoeuvres de cet ordre vous savez bien
que j'ai pris suffisamment de risques
dans la vie politique française pour ne
pas avoir à faire la preuve que je
déteste la duplicité
mais c'est noté emmanuel macron vous
l'aviez affublé du surnom peu aimable de
hologram
hologram c'est à dire une image elle
résiste un peu non cette image elle
prend de l'épaisseur qu'en maintenant
nous verrons pour l'instant je n'ai
aucune idée du programme ou de la
direction que
emmanuel macron défend je vois je vois
bien une présentation médiatique
flatteuse mais je ne vois pas la réalité
le fouet l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
donc nous allons nous allons voir dans
les semaines qui viennent de quelle
manière le paysage politique qui pour
l'instant n'est pas fixée pour
l'élection présidentielle et c'est le
moins que l'on puisse dire on a
l'impression que l'univers des surprises
n'est pas achevé on va voir comment tout
cela évolue sa demande à mûrir vous avez
terminé votre livre programme pendant
ses vacances de noël
oui oui il paraît qu'en derniers jours
de janvier dernier jour de janvier et la
primaire de la gauche et vous vous serez
prononcer avant on va préciser pas
attendre quelqu'un d'avoir exposé ses
idées lasser
c'est dans la première moitié du mois de
février que les choses prendront le tour
définitif alors vous disiez programme
qui vous interroge encore celui de
françois fillon est ce qu'il ya une idée
qui permettrait justement au candidat
élu l'est républicain deux vallées dire
de mettre plus de solidarité puisque
c'est un mot que vous avez utilisé dans
vos voeux au 31 décembre
dans son programme aux français si vous
voulez bien je vais essayer de proposer
des idées non pas pour les autres mais
pour moi parce que le rôle que je veux
jouer précisément dans cette période
c'est d'apporter des idées dans le débat
politique y en a pas beaucoup de
nouvelles on a l'impression très souvent
que ce sont des idées qu'on a déjà
entendu il ya longtemps et gaufres il a
pris votre avis oui ben c'est ce qui
vous frappe aussi n'en me semble-t-il
pas manquer quand j'entends les
commentaires
et donc pour moi oui je veux apporter
des idées nouvelles je vais en proposer
une c'est que la formation l'effort de
formation le devoir de formation que
nous avons à l'égard des des jeunes
français ça ne s'arrête pas à l'école
parce que beaucoup de jeunes sortent non
diplômés et beaucoup qui ont des
diplômes non pas deux
non plus parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
relations familiales ou autres
l'ouverture à l'égard du travail et donc
moi je propose qu'on crée un droit
nouveau qui est le droit à la première
expérience professionnelle c'est à dire
que on se charge la puissance publique
pôle emploi par exemple quand se charge
de proposer à tous les jeunes quand ils
sortent de formation un semestre
d'expérience professionnelle salariée
c'est à dire que c'est l'état qui c'est
l'état qui prend en charge
c'est l'état qui aident à trouver cette
première expérience professionnelle et
qui grâce aux énormes crédits de la
formation dont on sait pas vous savez
bien c'est donc c'est fini
sur les 30 milliards de l'information
oui c'est plusieurs dizaines de
milliards sont qu'on arrive parfaitement
à faire le point comme vous savez sur ce
sujet et donc qu' on puisse offrir à
tous les jeunes de leur mettre le pied à
l'étrier
vous savez bien quand ils veulent donc
c'est un droit un droit comme on dit
maintenant un peu universel pour tous
les jeunes qui sortent situation pour
tous les jeunes qui sortent de formation
qu'ils soient diplômés ou qu'ils ne le
soient pas d'avoir une première
expérience professionnelle salariée de
manière que quand ils ont ensuite à
présenter leur cv la première ligne du
cv est écrite et je suis certain que ça
peut changer le climat et le moral de du
pays des de cette génération parce que
le principal problème en l'autize et à
l'instant sur votre antenne c'est que il
ya une question de morale pour le pays
même si le moral
donc c'est l'assurance pour tous les
jeunes d'avoir un job de six mois à cdd
qui sera entièrement prise en charge par
l'état
j'ai pas dit entièrement parce qu'il
faut que l'entreprise y participent
aussi il n'y a pas de raison que l'état
soit ainsi un pourvoyeur mais l'état
complétera de manière que la charge pour
l'entreprise ne soit pas trop importante
et que ce soit une vraie première
expérience professionnelle donc c'est
votre idée dans votre livre programme
qui va apparaître fin janvier si le
en europe une des muses et si on
retrouvait celle là et d'autres dans le
programme de françois fillon s'avoue
satisfait mais je suis pas en train de
marchander là je suis en train de faire
vivre le débat national que nous devons
avoir et dans lequel chacun doit
apporter ses idées et sa vision et c'est
après qu'on regarde de quelle manière le
paysage se présente
la seule question je le répète c'est de
savoir si les idées que vous portez
elles sont défendues dans le débat
présidentiel
si elles ne le sont pas vous avez le
devoir de les faire entendre sur une
échelle de 1 à 10 votes détermination
aujourd'hui être candidat elle est de
franchement je n'ai aucune possibilité
de répondre à cette question parce que
si j'avais la réponse je vous la
donnerais encore une fois beaucoup de
gens qui rusent je n'appartiens pas au
nombre de ceux qui rusent je dis les
choses comme elles sont aussi
directement que je le peux et que je
vous parle en direct de la mairie de pau
merci à vous bonne journée à vous
françois bayrou qui vient de proposer un
droit universel de formation au premier
emploi premier job de six mois sur
l'antenne d'rtl
et concernant le pacte secret qu'ils
uniraient à françois fillon tout cela
est bidon faux fallacieux c'est de
l'intox nous a dit notamment le
président du modem merci à tous les deux
l'entretien bien entendu à retrouver sur
le site rtl.fr